على كل حال سالنا الناس في الاردن
والسعوديه كم عمرك وما هو العمر الذي تشعر
به يتابع
[موسيقى]
عمري 26 سنه بحس انه عمري 19 20 زي هيك يا
عمري 22
وبحس 22 يعني بحس انه الناس المفروض كل
واحد يعيش بمستوى العمر اللي هو وصله عمري
يعني
بحس حالي بال 30
[موسيقى]
51 والعمر اللي بشعر فيه فوق السبعين
سنه بشعر انه عمري بالستينات يعني انا
عمري 62 سنه اما اشعر عندما انظر الى
المراه اكبر من هيك بكثير حوالي 75 سنه
عمري 53 سنه
بشعر بعمر الشباب اللي هو
[موسيقى]
عمري 34
واحس اني 14 سنه عمري 49 سنه اؤمن جدا
بمقوله العمر مجرد رقم اشعر ان عمري في
بدايه الثالثه 73 واحس نفسي بالخمسين سنه
عمري عشرين
[موسيقى]
عمري 35 سنه
واحس كان عمري ميه عمري الفعلي 26 عمله مع
تراكمات الحياه في الاربعين عمري الحقيقي
32 سنه انا بحس ان انا 15 16 عمري تسعه
انا بس نفسي اكبر اكبر بسرعه
[موسيقى]